okay I think that issue poverty is
absolutely crucial unless you address
global poverty than many of the other
missionaries if you want to talk about
don't get addressed at all I am the
presence of the comics work up we
involve homeless people from many many
countries nearly 60 countries in the
world in playing football and then use
that as a way of taking them away from
on the street sending homeless and
they've done that feed it's been quite
successful now I think what we need to
do is build on the micro other's
projects such as the Amish Hamlet and
they get up with the private sector and
government section and trying commun
something which means global in its
appeal and global in its solutions world
economic forum and I think there is
generally a broader feeling amongst
Emily in all sectors but something has
to be done about poverty globally but
you know it's a question therefore if
everybody is agreeing probably should
desist all machined exist how do we
actually perceive its type of numbers so
what we try and do there for a license
is important is to explain things little
project phenomenal proper although it's
very very effective is actually training
on over lunch key is to try and connect
up all the little tiny projects learn
from each other partner from each other
and then take the whole thing to stay a
believer in hand up rather than a hand
out and so it's that type of philosophy
that has to learn to any solution people
living in poverty remember the solution
of the hands and what we can do is
create strategies and partnerships and
just get around to it
thank you